I come to this video playing Dagoberto
Daigle virtual from from Spain playing
this neo Philidor for a change let's see
what he's doing somewhat lame exchange
on yeah we got we get the normal video
it's taking some time maybe it's not
really an expert on this
yeah a force in general quite a useful
move for white to try to prevent b5 I'd
like to get in b6 a6 later b5 let's see
d5 now is the critical move on one
critical move okay I'm going to go a six
now yeah I guess I need to play this
Queen c7 is threaten to take a plane 95
depend on the D foul
yeah black wants to expand with b5 later
we should be 7 and b5 be nice to to get
in
you should eat soon this is prophylactic
or move normally to not let you not get
hit with b5 with the temple
sometimes Queen c4 as an idea not
interesting he wants to play the Knight
to f5 this does make of course some
sense especially after I have played the
bishop to be son okay and maybe really
Quincy for him
Quincy form could be could really be on
how does how do I protect maybe d5 takes
and b5 or something hmm I don't really
have anything else anyway hmm Quincy for
whatever playing against this d5 IDI
pinned I'm a pinned d5 Edie
not sure okay this is this is something
different now hmm I wonder if I should
actually if I should take and play we
see five this this opens up business but
also it opens up my pieces as well hmm
difficult difficult decision
see threatening something queen g3 maybe
maybe queen g3 what about d5 sd5 a move
trying to close this diagonal coogee
three still friends Knight h6 and the
side step maybe Wow hey I'm under
pressure this is not a not a very
comfortable position okay I need to play
among him it's not it's not a move that
I love to play absolutely not
but maybe my idea is to free e5 for the
night so that the knight can come to g6
rook takes Knight e5 Knight h6 check
King to H 8 and then 96 to 1 to protect
to protect the King of course I also
have c5 coming up
see five is of course a move that needs
to be considered cautiously as it also
weakens d5 but I want my bishop in play
definitely
the knight h6 is really just a check I
can sidestep can you play some some some
crazy stuff Knight h6 check King h8
Queen takes e5 I would be really crazy
we had but probably nothing nothing that
should worry me too much okay mmm
what is this can also try to just take
him maybe he could have taken on d6
actually rook I mean this mate on g7
okay I wonder if I can take now on e4
can I take now on e4
it's not spend any more time on this c4
and also was interesting trying to block
the bishop but if I can take the central
pawn I probably should do that it's also
very forcing I mean it probably must
take bishop takes and then I'm
threatening to just maybe take the night
off
this threatening piece would be nice to
exchange it's taking a long time hmmm I
really don't see anything great but it's
probably because I'm I'm overlooking
things should I just take it yeah I
guess
and no maybe I want to get rid of this
piece but maybe I can play a no Queen c6
he's got Bishop g5 I could play c4
though a c4 escutcheon making sure that
Bishop is not not getting involved
quickly
well it was a good news I guess I was
thinking about quince is six here anyway
I can also consider to take here on G -
Queen c6 is quite strong after that
quince is 6
timed crazy the smooth but maybe it's
working King takes Quincy six sure
definitely should definitely wins
because of Knight f3 either side diem
and I don't say if he moves the Queen
let's say to g5 or something or I think
that this should win check
I think his wins yeah
King H to orgy wanna have Knight f3 King
h1 I have this check and then Knight f3
this looks looks too much I can check
and play and here and here for Knight f3
now look here Ruby 6 coming said I'm
taking this rook I've been through which
is six also coming
white four things on time yeah I
definitely was under huge pressure yeah
how hard to believe that this shouldn't
be good for wine but okay let's let's
consider this the capture seems to be
best yeah computer also gives this of
course there is some logic counter to it
and opening up the position here for for
later c5 Queens is free and now c5 yeah
rook takes the six-year overlook this
move I mean only I saw it really late
maybe this is really the way to go funny
I'm not sure what I've played against as
I only saw it rather late the calm
suggestion is to play this one yeah that
makes some sense covering g7 and Queen
here and after this I mean this is
really a amazing computer chess the
computer I once played Bishop to d5 this
is totally inhuman Bishop to b5 white as
a rock down yeah so what is a rock down
and it's zero zero zero
it's stunt by that yeah he's the threat
is
I mean h5 is hanging and parcel in t7
and what this is this is a possible line
that he that the computer is giving
might have six check Wow check
no even going for that white being a
pawn up but it's not a clear PF fair as
he's got nothing developed this is
really crazy also there's also this move
check which directly forces the drone
this even losers and you wish that we
have the shack the perpetual amazing
okay we went here and it seems I can
really take it yeah okay no I did they
go in here
here I'm sorry again
yeah okay I had this crazy at DM chat
here with the with this
what is the compilation but just a
slight edge for black rook chicks if I
take with the pawn
check-check is this a draw
rook takes check just takes check here
check I can give the Queen back to try
to play for win this idea
they are crazy stuff but it was
interesting chat so this is the chat the
main line here deep
nohe wide wins even I must take okay so
how did this black should be better okay
it wasn't working but here I hear Knight
g6 was even stronger 96 was strong okay
and with this this idea now that that's
very good for black I'm just controlling
the the issue now there's nothing going
on the pawn and better pieces okay but
this also is also also winning okay okay
this is reassuring and Bishop g2 is the
best move great
so I actually saw something here it's a
decisive with Queen c6 coming
green juice research has it tougher
tougher defense yeah but this this is
just just winning just winning the game
so I guess this was a pretty pretty
decent pretty pretty decent game
actually okay thanks for watching